i'm still going to be protecting the
in-person experience the rest of my
freaking life here's what i'll say i
will agree with you everything in this
entire world over the last two years got
moved to zoom got moved to facetime and
so everything got worse in terms of like
being able to interact socially and
correct i went to a comedy show via zoom
during lockdown i refused to do one i
could not do it i couldn't do it it's so
weird it sounds like okay it's so weird
people on their way i mean look at look
at how many
strippers said all right strip clubs are
closed only fans boom they could work
from home they could work from home wfh
work from home work from anywhere
so i'm just saying that in my head i was
like
but how many of these only fan girls
made so much money this year that's what
we should look at but like when is it
going to be to the point where people
are more comfortable watching things
through screen than experiencing them in
person well it's going to get even
crazier with you know the metabolism
jenny got invited to go on a meta yacht
last week no you didn't yeah
i was going to be there with my trusa
with with snoop dogg as my dj partying
in the members in the jacuzzi
so you have to what put on a happy
birthday
and be on a yacht she's like listen i
want to go on a real [ __ ] yacht buddy
stop it so she declined that i declined
the offer yeah
the meta yacht i'm curious um is it
still available i want to go david wants
to go not have sensory like
people not sensory i just feel like i
really i really hope that
people in the millennial area
still keep adapting to the new times but
still keep human connection alive i know
because eventually everybody's going to
be in their houses in the little
metaverse
thinking
they're with people and they're by
themselves
[Music]